- [Narrator] Figure one, the horse.
This is a story about a horse.
(horse neighs)
A horse whose fate was inextricably tied
to the invention of film
and it all started with
an innocent question.
Do all four of a horses hooves
leave the ground at any
point during a gallop?
Leland Stanford, yes, the dignified chap
who founded Stanford University
thought they did.
- All four of the horses hooves
leave the ground while galloping.
- [Narrator] But some other
academics thought they didn't.
- One foot is most certainly
always touching the ground!
- [Narrator] So to put the matter to rest
Stanford hired a professional photographer
Eadweard Muybridge
to capture the truth on film.
There was a bet.
Thousands of dollars were at stake
as well as a man’s reputation.
But wait!
Cameras at the time could not
capture things moving quickly.
There was no such thing
as a movie camera in 1878.
So Muybridge had to get creative.
He devised an ingenious solution.
12 wired triggers and 12
shutters for 12 cameras.
All evenly spaced
to capture a horse and
carriage on a racetrack.
The carriage was driven
across the trip wires
setting off all 12 cameras
in less than half a second
capturing the truth.
- You can clearly see all four
hooves have left the ground.
(gasps)
- [Narrator] Leland Stanford was right.
But honestly, we don't
really care about the horse.
What we do care about, however,
is Muybridges newfangled contraption
used to photograph things in motion.
See what I'm getting at here?
Thomas Edison and the Lumière
brothers certainly did.
They took Muybridges invention
and changed the course
of media as we know it.
Creating the motion picture.
As for the academics who lost the bet?
They're fine, they had tenure.
(upbeat music)